l'actualité locale aussi marquée par des
violences attrape deux affrontements ont
éclaté ce week-end dans la commune dans
la nuit de samedi à dimanche un individu
a été agressé devant la mosquée à coups
de barres de fer et le lendemain ce sont
des affrontements qui ont éclaté dans le
quartier albert camus entre une
trentaine de personnes la police est
intervenue les forces de l'ordre ont
procédé à une interpellation et d'après
les premiers éléments de l'enquète il
s'agirait d'une rivalité entre bandes
écouter julien le cam secrétaire
départemental de police alliance le
secteur en ce moment effectivement il ya
de grosses tensions entre deux bandes de
jeunes un l'issue du square léo lagrange
et albert camus voilà ce qui est très
inquiétant c'est que la nuit dernière il
ya eu cinq blessés de nouveau à déplorer
dont un très sérieusement il faut savoir
que les riverains à l'origine on a
appelé les forces de l'ordre suite à des
bruits de détonation un qui était
certainement ici de tirs de mortier mais
il faut savoir que ces tensions et
peuvent on le sait il ya deux ans il ya
eu la mort d'un jeune dans le quartier
attrape le jeune moussa qui avait 14 ans
donc forcément c'est inquiète beaucoup
les forces de l'ordre